حسنًا ، مرحبًا ، أنا ذاهب إلى سفير من
Kadeem من كراكوف.
عبر دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ،
نقوم بنقل البضائع من الإمارات العربية المتحدة في كل مكان ،
ما هي خططك التوسعية في
المنطقة ، حسنًا ، تكون السعودية هي السوق الثانية
التي تدخلها ، لذا ستكون السوق الثاني
الذي ندخله ، ونتطلع أيضًا بشكل
أساسي للدخول في هذا الأمر الصعب ،
ومن المهم Mosca أن  افهم ما
هو المشهد التنظيمي في كل من هذه
الأسواق وما تسعى إليه كل دولة حقًا
من التكنولوجيا التي
تعرف أنها تجلبها شركات مثل كريم وسائق الشاحنات
والتي تشكل حقًا
عرضك للحكومة إذا كانت
الفرصة جيدة سترى
المنافسة طريقة جيدة للحصول على
الدعم من العلاقات
الحكومية من خلال المستثمرين المحليين ،
وهذه هي قيمة الكثير من المستثمرين المحليين الذين
تعرفهم وتحصل عليهم  بدأوا
فعليًا محفظتهم بالكامل أو أن
غالبية المحفظة في
البداية كانت مصنوعة من مستثمرين محليين
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة في المملكة العربية السعودية في الكويت وما إلى
ذلك ، وقد ساعد ذلك حقًا في فتح الأبواب
فقط حتى لا تحصل على خدماتنا
ولكن في الواقع للحصول على  لنا في مناقشة
مع الأشخاص المناسبين في
الحكومة وبعد ذلك ، فكيف يمكننا
دعم الحكومة لن نكون هناك
إذا لم تكن مضطرًا للابتكار
والمنافسة وحتى الخروج بأفكار أكثر ذكاءً
لتمييز منتجنا  إنها
نعمة مقنعة ، أحد
أسباب نمونا هو أيضًا أننا كنا
نفاد صبرًا لأنك تعلم أننا لا
ننتظر حتى يتم الانتهاء من التكنولوجيا
بالكامل لإدخالها في السوق
ويخرجون بتقنية 60٪
السوق يخبرك العملاء
أن آخر 40 بالمائة 100 بالمائة من
قيمنا هو اليوم ليس غدًا إذا كان
كل فرد في الشركة يؤمن
به ويفهم أنك فجأة
وفرت يومًا ما أو وفرت إلى البا.
أنت خارج السوق بشكل أسرع
وملف تعريف الارتباط الذي أنت موجود في السوق
والطباخ لديك MVP في
السوق والطباخ الذي تتعلمه ويمكنك تحسينه
والبقاء في الطليعة والبقاء في الصدارة والبقاء متقدمًا
على الآخرين نعم قليلاً من  لا شيء
لديه بطل
دائمًا. كان من دواعي سروري دائمًا
أن نبقى على اتصال ونرى كيف يمكن أن
نقيم شراكة معًا إلى الأمام ،
نعم لا أعرف ذلك أبدًا بسبب ملذاتي ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
شكرًا لك